our friends at points bet have
issued the odds for 2021 mvp the
favorite
the 2019 mvp patrick mahomes
or wait 2018. 2018 2019 was lamar
jackson man i can't keep these guys
straight
aaron rodgers 2020 lamar jackson 2019
patrick mahomes 2018. who was it in 2017
do you remember peter it was going to be
carson wentz uh
it was tom tommy it was tom brady in
2017. yeah all right so
who should be blank we're doing fill in
the blank so i have to say blank
should be the 2021 mvp favorite
uh i think patrick mahomes because
the chiefs are going to be really good
uh obviously
uh he's going to have the greatest
weaponry of anybody i'm not saying he
will win it but if i was making
a uh a betting line i'd definitely pick
my homes
can we put the screen back up because i
i look
mahomes probably should be the favorite
but
i'm intrigued by tom brady look
he's gonna have the whole year now to
get ready
to continue with the team that he just
took to the top of the mountain and he
was able to do it kind of on the fly
changing the tire on the moving car as
the season unfolded
you give him the full season you bring
back most of his guys
tom brady and and also just that that
whole you know the tom brady worship
justifiably so reaches a new level
if they come out and they're wire to
wire great
and they're the best team in the nfc and
tom brady has great numbers and he's 44
years old
i think that plus 1600 may be a pretty
good bet right now i still think that
going into the season my home should be
the favorite because peter i think he's
going to be ultra motivated
to come back and have a huge year just
like with tom brady losing a super bowl
how it torments him
losing in the super bowl is going to
torment patrick mahomes and he's going
to be ready to go
in in 2021 i believe
mike can you can you just go on a flight
of fancy with me for 15 seconds and tell
me
that you know the kansas city chiefs
this year and four quarters did not
score a touchdown
in the super bowl last year uh at the
eight minute mark of the fourth quarter
they had scored one touchdown they'd
scored ten points
so in seven and a half of the eight
quarters
that they've played in the last two
super bowls they've scored one touchdown
so i if i were andy reid
i would first of all i'd take some time
and work on my family
obviously but at some point in this off
season you know what i would start
thinking of
i would start thinking of uh why is it
that when we get in these huge moments
really huge moments
that we have really really struggled
and don't just tell me it's because we
didn't have our two tackles this year
if you're that paper thin you know and
to me i mean andrew wiley i think was a
disaster in the game the right tackle
but if you're that paper thin then you
know you and brett veach have to get
together and say
listen we gotta have four starting
tackles on the team this year
four four but but i think you have to
look at everything
coming off the last two super bowls and
coming off
let's let let's be honest down the
stretch of this season
look at the kansas city chiefs
struggling
mightily to beat the atlanta falcons
scoring whatever
17 points at home you know this
there are a few things with this offense
that in my opinion
i i'd have some concern about if i were
andy reid and eric the enemy
one thing that sims noticed as the year
went on there was more and more patrick
mahomes running for his life behind that
offensive line
who knows what caused that toe injury
but the guy was putting in a lot of
yardage behind the line of scrimmage
ideally you don't want him to have to do
that it's great that he can do it
you don't want him doing that all game
long week after week after week
obviously he's had surgery on that toe
it was a success as it always is we'll
see whether to what extent that affects
him in 2021 but i think he's going to be
determined
more motivated than ever and yet the
chiefs need to have
depth that's one of the keys when
patrick mahomes does that contract
that leaves money on the table one of
the things you leave money on the table
for peter is
depth is having quality backups
behind your starters so when someone
does get injured as it inevitably will
happen
you don't have a huge drop off and you
don't have a quarterback who is getting
uh harassed even more than usual in the
super bowl like we saw him
do eight days ago all right first mvp
in 2021
russell wilson because i think he's
going to be ultra uber
everything motivated as a member by the
way of the seattle seahawks
and i think that creative tension
between russell wilson and the combo
platter of pete carroll and john
schneider
i think that creative tension is going
to make the seahawks better
so give me russell wilson wow wow
see wow that's going to take a lot of
work offensively and it's going to take
a lot of
of ruffled feathers to unruffle to get
to the point where it's going to work
out that would be something if they why
do they have to be unruffled
why can't why can't they be a little
pissy with each other
you know how did they get how far did
they get being the welcome wagon
you know maybe maybe what the seahawks
should do
is use their first round pick on a
backup quarterback unfortunately they
don't have a first round pick to use on
a backup quarterback but that worked
that got aaron rodgers in a in in just
the right
sweet spot of being pissed off sorry
london
to to achieve the way that he did i'm
gonna say and this continues the trend
the second year quarterbacks that take
the league by storm
carson wentz 2017 would have been the
mvp
patrick mahomes 2018 his second year
just like went second year of the year
before
mahomes wins mvp lamar jackson 2019 his
second year
wins the mvp kyler murray was kind of on
track for that early on it fell off in
his second year how about peter
justin herbert as the nfl's mvp
in 2021 now again the charges would have
to be really really good
and or herbert would have to have a
historic season but he was so good
tapped on the shoulder when tyrod taylor
was unable to go because of
the misadventures of dr needle early in
the season
you give herbert the whole year as the
guy the sky's the limit for him
yeah the question is can the los angeles
chargers in the same division
as kansas city and to a lesser degree
las vegas i i can't see them
being any better than three and three in
their division who knows what happens
but
mike you know to win the mvp your team
has got to win 11 or 12 games i i think
at least
unless you're so transcendent and you
throw for 6 200 yards and you know you
do all these incredible things
but i it's it's hard for me to imagine
that the chargers are going to be 12 and
4. if they are
i definitely would put justin herbert in
that in uh
in that conversation the trend has held
for nine of the last 10 mvps
quarterback of a team with a one seed
in one of the two conferences is the mvp
aaron rodgers this year one seed in the
nfc
he's the mvp and that's the bookend he
was the one
seed 15-1 in 2011 in the nfc
won the mvp the only aberration is
adrian peterson the year that he made a
late run at the
single season rushing record all of
those other guys
i think mahomes in 2018 was a two seed
correct me if i'm wrong
no or were they the one seed either way
one seed or two seed back when they had
the bye week that got you consideration
to be the mvp mahomes also had a great
year in his first season as a starter
but it's quarterback from a great team
so we got a great quarterback with the
chargers we just need the charger to
have a great season for him to be in
contention for the mvp
player most likely to get an mvp vote
while playing on a new team is
[Laughter]
what a category this is this is
fantastic
player most likely to get a an mvp vote
uh matthew stafford
and and and that's because mike i i
think that the rams are gonna be
uh they've got a very good chance to be
a top
two seed in the nfc because
what were they lacking they were lacking
consistent quarterbacking
now look they're without brandon staley
i think raheem morris is going to go in
there and he's going to be
really really good for that defense
i thought that was an excellent choice
as coordinator
but to me mike i think matthew stafford
is going to have a giant
season uh playing under a coach who's
going to be determined to say
hey listen you see what we've been
missing watch us throw the deep ball
this year
yeah that's a great one and you know
what i'm also intrigued by where carson
wentz lands if it's indianapolis the
team could be very good the division
seems to be taking a step backward
whence whence as a potential mvp
candidate
if it clicks with him and frank reich
that would be something could be an mvp
candidate and comeback player of the
year candidate
although it reminds me of something that
shireen williams said when ryan
tannehill won it
in 2019 coming back from what sucking
which i guess that's still comeback
player of the year
you stink one year and you're good the
next year you're making a comeback
in some way shape or form um i'll say
carson wentz just for fun although i
agree with you matthew stafford's more
likely
the most likely non-quarterback to get
an mvp vote is who
say that again mike the most likely
non-quarterback to get an mvp vote is
who
um i think what i would say
it to that one is stefan diggs
because i think stefan diggs he's really
found his sweet spot
uh with that quarterback and uh
josh allen to stefan diggs i mean
it's entirely possible you know we just
voted a guy into the pro football hall
of fame and calvin johnson
who had the greatest season that that a
wide receiver ever had
but i want you to think of something for
a second mike
do you realize that no player in nfl
history
no wide receiver has ever averaged
125 yards a game now does that seem
absolutely outrageous it doesn't to me
and i realize the consistency you'd have
to have is absolutely great
but i think right now with the bombs
away mentality of josh allen
i think he's going to be better next
year and he was damn good this year
i think stefan diggs has a chance to be
the nfl's
first 2000 yard receiver hey peter
he's only going to need 117 this year
because it's gonna be 17 games i mean i
think it's doable
i think it's doable i remember this must
have been 10 years ago
when i asked aaron rodgers when the
explosion of quarterback numbers
and i said to him how far away for are
we
from a six thousand yard passer you know
a six thousand yard passing season
at the time i think uh i i forget i
think matthew stafford had just thrown
for
five thousand or something but but i
mean you know people were
were edging over five thousand and and
he said oh that's
that's too much and i i forget what he
said but he was
very dubious and i think his point
was pretty interesting i mean as i
extrapolated it later
you could average 375 passing yards a
game
which is just absurd you almost have to
run the run and shoot
but i do think that it is doable
for a receiver you know to average 125
yards a game very hard
but doable and if that happens the guy
in football right now
i see having the best shot is stefan
diggs if he had a
000 yard receiving season he'd get an
mvp vote
let me let me pick another guy who's
connected in a roundabout waiters to
fawn diggs
because the vikings traded diggs and
then used a first-round pick
on justin jefferson who exploded once he
finally got onto the field the first
couple of weeks they didn't know what
they had
he didn't play much gary kubiak put him
in the starting lineup week three
he breaks randy moss's record for
receiving yardage by a rookie with the
vikings
justin jefferson could have a gigantic
year there's going to be a ton of
pressure on this vikings offense they
opted for consistency
by elevating clint kubiak who's going to
run the same system his dad did gary
retired this year uh and they're gonna
need to get the ball down the field and
justin jefferson has proven that he can
be
very dynamic in that offense year two
for him
trust him from week one adam feeling to
take some of the heat off
dalvin cook getting the rushing yards
justin jefferson could have a huge year
and he could be a guy who gets an mvp
vote all right last one
well first here did you know russell
wilson has never had an mvp
vote in which week of the season peter
say that one again we'll first hear
the quote did you know russell wilson
has never gotten an mvp
vote in what week of the season yeah
uh three after yeah week three
after he's thrown for 1300 yards in the
first three weeks
and people will say you know one of the
biggest
uh it's such an outrage
that russell wilson has never gotten an
mvp vote
and i will kind of calmly very calmly
explain to every person
and say this you know there is only
there's 50 voters
and you only have one vote per year so
there have been 450 mvp
votes since russell wilson was the 75th
pick
in 2012. but if you go over every year
i can't find a year where i would have
voted for russell wilson
or even close for mvp i shouldn't say
even close
i mean he would have been in my top
three or four a couple of times
but it's it's not it's just not
outrageous
it's it's peculiar but it's not
outrageous
i wonder how much of that is motivating
this this
push for whatever it is he's looking for
he wants the offense to run through him
you're not going to be the mvp of the
league if the offense doesn't run
through
you and here he is entering year 10 and
he's never even had a single mvp
vote that has to you know these guys are
so competitive in
everything they do it has to drive him
nuts
that he's never gotten an mvp vote so i
think we'll hear about it week one
this year it's so well known he'll be
having a big performance and they'll say
it during the game whoever the seahawks
open the season with it'll be brought up
during the game
that russell wilson's never had an mvp
vote all right uh that's that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports